i want to go through with you today a
few different clips of the
extraordinarily
childish
humiliating anti-mask tantrums that
we're seeing around the country on
yesterday's show i had coverage of this
anti-vaccine mandate rally in new york
city
and it was crazy there are also now more
and more school districts as school has
already started for the fall in some
places and is within a week or two of
starting in other places there are more
and more places that are um now having
hearings school board hearings of
various kinds and there are furious
parents showing up and saying no masks
for my kids now i'm not going to belabor
this point but i've made it before and
i've tweeted about it and many of you
seem to agree
i'm imagining if i'm a nine-year-old
in school
and i am told
there are going to be
mask requirements in school but don't
worry little johnny
i'm going to go crazy
demanding they not force you to wear a
mask
i think that the wearing of the mask
wouldn't be that bad compared to knowing
my mom is going cuckoo for coco puffs on
zoom meetings and at a school board
meeting right i think that that would be
far worse for the kid but at the end of
the day i am not a parent so i guess i
can't say for sure but that's certainly
my instinct let's take a look at some
examples here is an anti-master at the
shenandoah i know that the word is
probably it's the the root of it seems
to be the same as shenandoah but it's
the different spelling i believe it's
pronounced shenandahawa central school
district meeting
uh in new york maybe it is just
pronounced shenandoah even though it's
spelled in a way i've not seen before
okay in any case here is
some crazy scenario where a parent says
um it's possible that the masks will
lead to sexual assault my guess is that
they they say because you wouldn't know
who it is because they're wearing it
let's say your son or daughter is about
to become that 10
statistic they're being led down the
hallway by the rapist they're walking
casually on by passing students and
teachers along the way the students and
teachers are smiling at the soon-to-be
victim behind their mass but nobody can
see the smile they disappear and your
child is violently raped
what we didn't know is that the rapist
had told your child that if he or she
said a word to anyone as they were
walking they would kill them
what we didn't know is that your son or
daughter
excuse me
i was smart enough to mouth the words
help me
because they were being led away
oh i see and so if they're wearing a
mask they wouldn't be able to mouth that
all the while we were smiling at this
victim behind our mask the victim was
trying to communicate their distress to
us without the use of vocal words
we failed their son or daughter in those
moments and they were raped
we could have stopped such a violent act
from occurring but our choice to be
complicit
it's it's it's kind of like a weird
disaster porn i mean that's an insanely
specific scenario i don't i don't know
really what to make of it other than
if you have to come up with such crazy
scenarios to justify why
just the kids shouldn't all wear masks
to prevent the spread especially since
they're mostly not vaccinated yet
you're probably reaching beyond what
makes sense is sort of my instinct
here's another one this is an
anti-massacre at higley unified school
district in gilbert arizona the video is
very dark i don't know why it's just the
video we have and she says science is
ridiculous i can't figure out by now
the science is ridiculous then you're
probably driving around in your car with
a mask on by yourself and i can't help
you at this point nor do i want to it's
not my job i appreciate what you want to
do for you and your family i would
appreciate it if you respected what i
did for me and my family because that's
where we live the united states of
america
god bless america
the end
thank you
and i am as disturbed by
the applause that this stuff gets
uh as i am by the content of it and just
really funny thing the the woman sort of
has a look like roseanne barr
and roseanne barr's former former
husband tom arnold who's a supporter of
the david pakman show the first response
on twitter is i swear roseanne used to
be funny um but this is this is really
really bad really really bad and
unfortunately the amount of support it
gets is maybe the scariest uh the
scariest part altogether and then lastly
here here's an anti-master that
completely loses his mind
at a meeting of the board of
commissioners in ottawa county michigan
let's listen to that dan vander swagg
here comes dan
that's my father-in-law right there
speaking on behalf of my his grandkids
you with that diaper on your face if he
farted right now could you smell it
that's how stupid this is
we're all playing games here with
people's lives
now let me address that because there's
this is a talking point that's been
spreading and it's it's spreading uh
not intentionally using a pun this is a
talking point that's been floating
around which is is th if you can smell
something through the mask as the as the
gentleman here astutely points out and
decorously points out if you can smell a
fart through the mask then it couldn't
really be protecting you from covid
this is this is actually so simple
the smell from a fart is caused by um
some version of methane i think it's
called like methanthiol or something
like that
and
you know like sulfur-containing
molecules the point is the the molecules
that contain the fart smell are really
really small they're way smaller than
coronavirus coronavirus droplets are up
to 34 000 percent larger than fart smell
carrying molecules so it's such a stupid
topic but at the same time it keeps
getting repeated if you can smell
through the mask clearly it's doing
nothing no no no let's look at the size
of the molecules and of course the knit
of the mask also makes a difference
let's listen to a little more of this
guy and i'm sick of it i would represent
all these hard-working guys that
couldn't be here today
to
take off work to put up with this bs
that you guys are putting down
and there's hell coming
there's home coming and i'm not doing it
to threaten anybody but there's a lot of
good guys out there ready to do bad
things soon
watch what's coming
not him he would never do that stuff
he's not threatening us but he's just
letting us know other people might do
stuff if they have to wear them mandates
are against the nuremberg
uh oh now it's gone completely off the
first line states
voluntarily informed consent
all right i can't even i can't even
listen to any more of that so that's
what's going on
and if these people put five percent of
the energy into helping to end the
pandemic that they put into things that
would help prolong it uh we might be out
of it by now
let me know your thoughts find me on
twitter at d pacman
when we're talking about sleep we always
hear about how much sleep people get but
often neglected in the conversation is
the quality of that sleep which is just
as important and science shows that
lowering your body temperature during
sleep can help you be more rested and
achieve better sleep and that's where
our sponsor chili sleep comes in chili
sleep makes customizable climate
controlled sleep solutions to help you
improve your sleep comes in two
varieties the uhler sleep system and the
cube sleep system that's what i have on
my bed both are hydro powered
temperature controlled luxury mattress
pads you can make your bed as cold as 55
degrees i choose 60.
you can make it as hot as 115 degrees if
that's your thing
i don't feel hot anymore at night no
more sweating i'm sleeping better and i
love it i also have the chili sleep
chili blanket which helps keep me cool
on top as well they'll give you twenty
percent off everything when you go to
chilisleep.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video